PEOPLE WHO ARE ABLE TO FILL UP
ON ELECTRICITY INSTEAD OF GAS.
>> Sean: EVEN MORE OUT OF
TOUCH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO FEDERAL RESERVE
BANK WHO MAKES NEARLY HALF
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
SUGGESTING AMERICANS SHOULD STOP
COMPLAINING ABOUT INFLATIONS
BECAUSE YOU HAVE ENOUGH.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> I DON'T WANT THE PAIN OF
INFLATION ANYMORE.
I SEE PRICES RISING BUT I HAVE
ENOUGH THAT I CAN MAKE
SUBSTITUTIONS AND DO THINGS, SO
I AM NOT IMMUNE TO PRICES
RISING.
I SOMETIMES BALK AT THINGS BUT I
DON'T FIND MYSELF WHERE I NEED
TO MAKE TRADE-OFFS.
MANY AMERICANS HAVE ENOUGH.
>> Sean: YOU HAVE ENOUGH, STOP
BEING SO GREEDY.
CHARLES PAYNE IS WITH US.
I WAS A LITTLE SURPRISED, I SAW
THIS ON FOXNews.com, MANCHIN
VOTES WITH BERNIE SANDERS 80% OF
THE TIME, CHUCK SCHUMER, 91% OF
THE TIME.
YOU KNOW, JUST TO GIVE CONTEXT
TO THIS, SUSAN COLLINS ONLY BOTH
WITH MITCH McCONNELL 62% OF
THE TIME, LINDSEY GRAHAM, 70% OF
THE TIME, SO YOU CAN SEE THAT
MANCHIN IS PRETTY MUCH A
CHUCK SCHUMER, BIDEN DEMOCRAT.
HE LIKES TO PORTRAY HIMSELF AS A
MODERATE, HIS VOTING RECORD
SHOWS JUST THE OPPOSITE.
>> HE'S DONE A GREAT JOB AT A
FALSE PROMOTION.
I REALLY WANT TO GO AFTER THIS
BILL AND THE WAY THAT PEOPLE
JUST NEED TO UNDERSTAND, THE
INTERNATIONAL ENERGY AGENCY,
WHICH IS A BIG INTERNATIONAL
GROUP OF FOLKS WHO HAVE A LOT OF
POWER, AND HE PUT AT THE SUPPLY
CHAIN REPORT FOR VEHICLES, IS
WHAT THE WORLD WILL NEED, THE
WORLD, 50 MORE LITHIUM MINES, 60
MORE NICKEL MINES, 60 MORE
COBALT MINES, SO THEY COME FROM,
THE COBALT COMES FROM CONGO.
HER BUSY VIDEOS OF THE KIDS IN
FILTHY WATER FOR EIGHT HOURS, 12
HOURS A DAY, NO EDUCATION,
PENNIES ON THE DOLLAR.
SOME LITHIUM COMES FROM
AUSTRALIA AND CHILE, AFTER
POISON THE WATER.
INDONESIA, THE NICKEL.
THERE ARE FIVE STAGES FROM
GETTING FROM THE RAW MATERIAL TO
THE FINISHED PRODUCT.
SO EVEN IF YOU LOVE THE CLIMATE
ISSUE ITSELF, THE PRESIDENT IS
LYING TO YOU.
THIS BILL DOES NOTHING ON THE
CLIMATE SIDE.
WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
STRIP MINE THE PLANET AND POISON
THE WATERS.
SO AS YOU GO ALONG THROUGH THE
PROCESS YOU'VE GOT THE
MATERIALS, YOU START TO PROCESS
IT, CHINA TAKES A A GREATER
SHARE.
AND THEN YOU GET THE BATTERIES,
THIS IS THE MOST IMPORTANT PART
TO REMEMBER.
WHEN THE WHITE HOUSE TALKS ABOUT
ENERGY SECURITY I GUESS THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT THOSE BATTERIES.
CHINA HAS A 70% SHARE AND 80%
SHARE.
OUR SHARE WILL GO FROM 9% TO
50%.
THE ONLY PART OF THE EQUATION WE
PLAY A ROLE AND IS AT THE VERY
END OF IT.
WE BUY THESE THINGS.
THE RICHEST AMERICANS, COLLEGE
GRADS WHO LIVE IN URBAN SETTINGS
TO BUY THESE CARS.
IF THEY CAN AFFORD THEM ON THEIR
OWN THEY DON'T NEED ANY
INCENTIVE.
AND THAT THEY DON'T NEED THE
TAXPAYERS' MONEY, SOMEONE
DRIVING A CAB FOR LIVING.
AS A COMPLETE FARCE, THERE'S
NOTHING ECONOMIC ABOUT IT AND
THERE WAS NOTHING, ZERO, ZERO TO
EVEN SAVE THE CLIMATE.
>> Sean: YOU ARE THE ONLY
PERSON I KNOW WHO HAS BEEN
TALKING ABOUT IT AND YOU ARE
100% RIGHT.
AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE WILL ON
AVERAGE COST 20 GRAND MORE THAN
A GAS POWERED VEHICLE.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
SO YOU HAVE TO MINE FOR NICKEL,
FOR COBALT, MANGANESE AND ALL
THESE OTHER MINERALS.
USE BIG, HEAVY EQUIPMENT TO DO
SO, THEN YOU MAKE THESE
BATTERIES AND HOW DO YOU CHARGE
THEM?
80% OF OUR GRADE, THE POWER GRID
IS NOT ABOUT RENEWABLES.
ONLY 12% IS.
SO YOU ARE USING NATURAL GAS AND
COAL TO CHARGE HER ELECTRIC
VEHICLE IN YOUR GARAGE OR YOUR
CHARGING STATION AND YOU PAY
MORE FOR THAT AS WELL.
SO THE BOTTOM LINE IS THEY ARE
STILL BEING FUELED IN THAT SENSE
FROM MOTHER EARTH AND FOSSIL
FUELS AND OF COURSE, YOU'RE
RIGHT.
MINING ALL OF THESE AREAS AND
DESTROYING THE ENVIRONMENT IN
THAT PROCESS.
>> WE ARE NOT DRILLING A HOLE IN
THE GROUND AND CRACKING ROCKS.
WE ARE STRIPPING THE PLANET AND
POISONING THE WATERS AND HERE'S
THE CRAZY THING, WE JUST HAVE TO
LOOK TO EUROPE.
FRANCE AND GERMANY, THEIR
ELECTRICITY RATES WILL BE 1000%
HIGHER THIS WINTER.
1000% HIGHER THAN THE AVERAGE
PRICE OF THE LAST TEN YEARS.
THERE ARE COSTS TO THIS
COMMITMENT MAGIC FAIRY DUST LIKE
SOME DEMOCRATIC CONGRESS PEOPLE
BELIEVE.
I AM SO GLAD I AM NOT SUFFERING.
OF COURSE YOU ARE SUFFERING.
THIS THING IS ABSOLUTELY
DEVASTATING, ALL THIS IS IS A
MONEY TRANSFER TO THE RICHEST
AMERICANS OUT THERE.